I'm sure you have noticed that this class has a subtitle, cognitive systems.
Let's talk about this term and break it down into its components. Cognitive,
in this context, means dealing with human-like intelligence. The ultimate goal
is to dwell up human level, human-like intelligence. Systems, in this context,
means having multiple interacting components, such as learning, reasoning and
memory. Cognitive systems, they are systems that exhibit human level,
human-like intelligence through interaction among components like learning,
reasoning and memory. Thus, on a spectrum, what we'll discuss in this
class will definitely lie on the right side of the spectrum, on the human side.
We will be talking about thinking and acting, but
we will always be concerned with human cognition.